chris bubich the starter 13th start the
lefty for kansas city yeah and the
cardinals looking to see if they could
jump on him early in this one saw him
last week four and two thirds only gave
up one but lots of opportunities
a big deep breath the wind up the pitch
tommy loops it into right center field
that ball is going to drop a base hit
edmond takes the turn at first and he
adds to a 265 batting average while
batting right-handed the runner goes the
pitch is swung on base head right field
moving to his right dozier comes up with
the ball throws to the middle infield
and the cardinals have runners at first
and third with no body out all arenado
has done in this series is drive in six
runs and that'll be a base hit into
right one nothing cardinals
scoring tommy edmond three consecutive
hits to start the ball game one-nothing
cardinals rondon up with the bases
loaded two down the pitch a swing and a
hit to left center that ball is smoked
backhanded in the gap by ben and tendy
and the cardinals get two runs out of it
on a double by rondon 3-0 st louis in
the first in comes the pitch and a fast
ball is hit in the air to right dozier
to his left he's there to make the catch
finally gets it done and the royals
are facing jay happ his
overall era with minnesota and st louis
is 6.3
but it's much higher than that over his
last 16 starts
and he goes the other way and that is
going to drop so the wind
again is a factor blowing in from right
whit didn't hit it hard it sounded like
he broke his back but the win really
knocked that down and newt barr had no
chance
ground ball right side let's see if they
could turn two out there it's a double
play four six three edmond sosa goldie
cardinals now turned four double plays
in the series paul goldschmidt against
kansas city eight for 21. bunch of runs
batted in now the pitch the ultimate
hits it hard and it goes off the glove
of third baseman rivera down the left
field line tommy edmond races for third
he's coming on a round he's going to
score it's a double and an rbi for paul
goldsmith four-nothing cardinals here's
aronado he's hit safely in five straight
arronado
smokes it down the left field line
toward the foul pole and that's a home
run a home run for nolan arenado and the
cardinals have put up three runs in the
second inning
o'neal swings and he lifts a high fly
ball deep center field this might go
and it's back to back home runs for
oronato and tyler o'neal for the second
time in this series seven nothing
cardinals the next by boobitch
and nubar sends it out to center it's
well hit and down
extra bases lars newpar on base for the
second time and here comes
new
listen to the newt cheer that shows you
how many cardinal fans are here tapia
comes on with the royals down seven
nothing in the second inning the pitch
on the way a swing and a broken
background ball to third handled by
rivera who throws out sosa eight
cardinals came to bat four scored we
have back to back home runs from arnotto
and o'neill cam gallagher has gone two
for three facing half he's up with the
bases loaded two outs the 2-2 pitch for
the base is loaded a swing and the
ball's hit in the air left center field
on the run bader he makes the play and
is running toward the dugout so the
royals leave the bases loaded urban
santana 27th appearance this season
seven nothing our score
o'neil swings and misses and strikes out
the bullpen so far has done a nice job
for mike matheny's royals the one-two
pitch
swinging bunt baiter
will beat it out and a two-out hit
infield hit harrison bader the 01 is
swung on hit in the air left side
playable for ben and tendy and he'll
make the catch and that will do it for
the cardinals no run
the next one from santana that's stroked
into right center field and it gets down
for a hit backhanding the ball
dozier holding sosa to a long one out
single in the fifth inning though he
swings the bet well the pitch is swung
on double play ball to short out at
second and on to first kisner is out
double play courtesy of andrew kisner it
goes six four three
so one out nobody on and goldie sends it
out to center fielder michael a taylor
using the
right hand to shade from the sun has the
glasses down makes the catch goldschmidt
two for four with a single a double
the pitch
swung on and miss struck him out santana
has been solid throwing three shutout
innings since coming in in the fourth
inning santana leads it off here in the
home half of the sixth been a tough home
stand for santana now one for 23. as he
flies to right lars is under it new bar
makes the catch santana's out
andrew bennett
hit the ball hard three times today he
is two out of three as one out was a
line drive to deep right field so a
single on a walk after two outs hunter
dozier is coming up the kick and the
pitch a swing and a fly ball right field
that's it well
lars back on the track newt bart johnson
he makes the catch in the corner that's
a tough corner to make a play with the
curved wall in the right left field
corners here but newt barr he had an
idea of his location and then left his
feet at the last second so gallagher
will bat apparently a uh nelly fan
that's his walk-up song
that is a slider hit down the left field
line long way to go for o'neill on the
run he lays out and he makes the play
what a play by tyler o'neill the
cardinals defense has been outstanding
and mundo sosa clapping his hands so is
nolan arenado and so
is the pitcher luis garcia justin miller
comes on with a 7.07 era
hit well right center field
and
a
trap
on a really good attempt by bader and
santana will end up at second base with
a one-out double salvador perez will
back man on second base with uh one out
oh baby there we go that'll get him on
the board
and that'll get the fans out of their
seats
salvador perez it's his 30th home run
for the first time in his career and it
was his 400th career extra base hit
congratulations salvi 12 games so far
for t.j mcfarland been really good he
comes out of the redbird bullpen for the
13th time 1-2 pitch and he struck him
out then the cardinals throw the ball
around the infield lopez strikes out
ground ball to short
sosa
over to first the cardinals have won a
six in a row it's a sweep of the road
trip